As of the date of this recording, Epic has assembled a number of tips and resources that
can provide you with the extra technical information and workflow suggestions designed to improve
your knowledge of the engine.
When you factor in third-party websites, authorized Unreal instructor platforms, and
Unreal partners, the number becomes far too many to list in this presentation.
However, here are a few simple sequencer tips and resources that you can use to get yourself
underway.
Within Sequencer, the following tips will help improve your efficiency.
Right middle mouse button and drag will pan the timeline horizontally and vertically.
Shift and scroll will also pan the timeline.
Control and scroll is used for zooming the timeline.
Alt shift right mouse drag can be used for freeform zooming around the time marker, and
pressing the home key on your keyboard will reset the range slider bounds.
Control drag on the time bar and moving the mouse to the right will define a specific
zoom region, whereas control drag on the time bar to the left will reset the zoom region.
There are also a number of hotkeys that can come in handy for setting keyframes, centering
your timeline, and duplicating selected items.
If you have specific technical questions, the Unreal developers website is a great place
to start in order to find a number of resources including engine documentation and video-related
content.
Epic also provides a number of links within the slide deck for you to explore.
Take some time and take a look.
This concludes our quick start for Sequencer Shot creation.
I hope you learned something and enjoyed this class.
Thank you.